Jenna Dewan is responding to everyone
saying she looks like Channing Tatum's
new girlfriend Jessie J Jenna Dewan and
Channing Tatum shockingly split back
back in April Channing started dating
singer Jessie J last month and a lot of
people are all up in all their social
media comment sections making
comparisons to Jenna and Jessie J say
may have a striking resemblance I see
the resemblance but here is what a fan
wrote to Jenna on Instagram whenever I
hear of the striking resemblance with
Jessie J - Jenna Dewan my only thoughts
aren't mom no not even close I don't
have a horse in the race but girlfriend
you are untouchable just trying to send
positive vibes keep doing you and she
responded positive vibes all the way
which I'm surprised she even responded I
mean she must have been getting a lot
yeah I think she was probably getting a
bombarded with comments but I'm glad
that she took the high road here yeah of
course we want to know do you guys first
okay I understand they're not like
carbon copies of each other and you can
clearly see Jessie J that's Jenna Dewan
but as soon as I saw they were dating I
was like Oh Channing has it right I did
think that but I think there's both
strikingly beautiful and they fade out I
saw it when I'm like scrolling really
fast like okay I see you both have like
the the Bob thing going on similar style
I think they're both beautiful in their
own right
of course it seems that Jenna is very
happy in her relationship she told et
this on a red carpet and I'm happy for
her and Steve he seems like you know a
really good guy he's a Tony Award
winning actor just all-around good
person that's the thing is like it
there's no reason for Jenna to be bent
out of shape about any of this like
she's moved on to there they're all
doing great exactly and I know we were
talking about this earlier Chris Pratt
and on Affairs they seem to have done
the same thing when it comes to rebounds
but it's worked out they are the couple
that everyone's like if they break up I
will lose faith in love and then they
did and then they both move on and then
we see them like trick-or-treating
together and they're still getting along
and I love it and we're happy we're very
happy for both of these couples I think
they're a good example of like what exes
can be and honestly like I want to see
Jessie J tennis one hanging out I do
obviously that I feel like that would be
a fly on the wall need to be there
co-parenting is a priority for Jenna and
Channing the source says Channing
wants to do nothing but support Jessie J
in every way so it seems like across the
board Channing is supportive yeah
and a source adds that Jessie J has had
some very difficult relationships in the
past this relationship is everything
she's been searching for and she
deserves it
think she does deserve it and on that
note Jessie J and Channing do seem to be
very supportive of each other we know
Channing was at her London concert and
said the Jessie J poured her heart out
on stage hear her heart out and then we
later find out that she did this really
heartfelt moment with the concert goers
where she reportedly revealed that she
couldn't have children I think that's
like a really big moment to share with
the world but also Channing being the
audience was probably know and III don't
know if we talked it out beforehand or
anything that's none of our business
but I really do think that they could be
a really lovely couple it seems like
they're moving in the right direction
things could be serious of course this
is all speculation and we just want to
keep that conversation going they've
been really supportive I'd love to see
Jessie J as a bonus mom in the future
that's just my take I know and I think
like Jenna Jenna's gotta be thrilled
that somebody like Jessie J who is so
you know awesome and powerful and strong
is going to be somebody that could be
around Everly right exactly I think both
both show some really great partners so
blended families in the future I want to
be a good thing all right so with all
this talk with Jenna supporting Jessie J
are all signs pointing to a successful
blended family in the future I hope so
do we think exes and new girlfriend's
can be friends do we want to see them
hanging out because I do dominate in the
world all right let us know we want to
keep that conversation going and we want
to see that hangout session happen of
course I'm at Kourtney underscore tezo
know and I'm at ash Crossin until next
time we've got you covered for your pop
culture fix
you